he's a liberal and is proud of it what's
a different you know liberal and a
progressive I don't know anymore
actually of course the term is used
completely differently in Europe from
the United States liberal in Europe is
free-market liberal in the US tends to
mean you want more government
intervention so the term is pretty
confused term actually presidential
candidates move to the middle the
Secretary Clinton had the ability to
move to the middle or she seen so much
from the senator from Vermont that she's
gonna have to keep some of that liberal
heritage to keep her base oh she's
absolutely in the middle and is the
status quo candidate by her own account
and her own positioning she says I want
to continue the past eight years a lot
of the electorate though overwhelmingly
says we're on the wrong direction by a
huge margin and this is the tension I
mean its attention but is it solved by
just economic growth do what you what
you've observed being active with
senator Sanders does the angst go away
with better GDP growth I don't buy it
for a minute I think it's societal there
is a lot of angst today there's a story
running of a new study showing that
suicide rates and yes stains gone
significantly it's it's shocking
it shows how corrosive the current
situation is for a lot of people in this
country it's it's really stunning to
read this because we've plateaued on
rising life expectancy something that we
tend to have thought is automatic but
it's hardly automatic we're seeing
really a corrosive social phenomenon in
our country right now professor Sachs is
this because I mean you can have GDP
growth that helps as long as it's
distributed more fairly and do you think
you we has had a material impact in
fostering this inequality we know that
inequality in the United States has been
rising now for 30 years this has gone on
across administrations Republican
presidents Democratic Party presidents
we took the position in this country
already 30 years ago basically starting
with the Reagan administration
that we're not going to use
redistributive policies that basically
were going to be in a low tax low
government spending era and this has
been part of the story of why the Gini
coefficient the measure of inequality in
the United States has soared that hasn't
happened in countries where there's been
more active government policy especially
northern Europe to say that every kid
every poor kid has the same chance as a
middle class or richer kid in our
country we've just basically allowed the
inequality to widen for decades
especially for lower skilled workers
real incomes have been going down now
for years and years
there's nothing changing this trend and
I think there's a tremendous amount of
unhappiness about it well we see a
reversal in that trend depending I guess
on who comes to power you can always see
a reversal if there is a change of
politics and policy in this country
basically in a different vision of how
fiscal policy works the countries that
keep low inequality and again those are
mainly northern Europe the countries
like Denmark Sweden Norway Netherlands
Germany work at it quite hard they tax
more than the United States and they
distribute more than the United States
in terms of single-payer health care or
free tuition for a higher education or
childcare vacation support when we do
studies which I put out with colleagues
every year so-called world happiness
report the u.s. comes out rather low
among the high-income countries the
countries that do more redistribution
have lower inequality are less stressed
less tense and happier and it's showing
up now in life expectancy and other
dramatic indicators in your book the
price of civilization you have a chapter
called the rigged game
you were four years ahead of what we're
seeing right now whether it's mr. Trump
or mr. Sanders there is a pervasive
belief that it's a rigged game hoody
rigs us who is the one who's the
institution that says we need to be less
rigged
well the rigging is basically by the
incumbents who are together with the the
lobbyists and the billionaires and we
know that the whole political process
has gone wildly awry the Supreme Court
gave it a big kick in the wrong
direction with Citizens United in all
those other opinions that couldn't tell
the difference of free speech and
anonymous corporate contributions really
shocking the Supreme Court gutted the
regulations of of how we do election
financing in this country so the game is
rigged
Americans are sick of it that every time
you see a candidate there's a
billionaire behind that candidate and or
a billionaire running himself you
haven't do you have an optimism that
President Clinton could write the ship
well she's absolutely a core part of
this whole process that's that was how
the whole Democratic Party moved it was
starting with Bill Clinton was to pair
up with Wall Street back in in 1992 it
changed the the nature of our politics
the Supreme Court opened up the spigots
entirely people are really disgusted and
some though someday a candidate whether
it's Bernie Sanders or someone else is
gonna win on the basis of small
contributions not on the basis of the
billionaires someday